bill o'brien out after only four games
as the head coach and general manager of
the texans and literally he had only
four games
as officially the gm of the team and now
he's gone
and i think we both had the same
reaction mike holy crap i mean it was
stunning uh and and not stunning at the
same time i mean it's a guy that went 52
and 48 he was planted to take over the
play calling duties again next week and
that's obviously not going to happen it
might have been a little more fun if
he'd either been fired as gm or fired as
head coach but he was obviously fired as
both and romeo cornell is now going to
step in a former head coach
and be the head coach the rest of the
season but this is a bad ball club uh
and and it's not going to get any better
for them they just don't have a whole
lot of talent outside of
the obvious guys the quarterback and j.j
white and there's just not a lot to
build around i think he failed as gm as
much as he felt as coach
well i agree and look i i have said
multiple times in recent days that
every coach needs
another voice a persuasive voice an
influential voice not jack easter be
nothing against jack easterby he's not
the voice that is in place to say to
bill o'brien
maybe you should just try to work out
your issues with deandre hopkins instead
of trading maybe you should press pause
on that i mean we've seen some impulsive
moves by bill o'brien
that would be no different than the
impulsive moves other coaches would make
if there's no one in the building
to say
time out we have unlimited timeouts in
this facility we don't have to hold them
we don't have to use them strategically
anytime we want to press pause we can
let's take a break let's make sure this
is what we should be doing look at how
quickly on
and this was when they didn't have a gm
but bill o'brien was essentially the gm
labor day weekend of 2019 boom big trade
for laramie tunzel two first-round draft
picks without signing into a long-term
contract strike one
the judaevian clowny thing where they
end up paying
seven million dollars of his salary
to get him off the roster and to get not
a whole lot in return for him from the
seahawks i mean there have been signs
that this wasn't working but the
validation came after the 2019 season
they
won
the division they won a playoff game
they were leading
the kansas city chiefs 24 to nothing in
the divisional round of the playoffs and
then they get the
schedule from hell
to start the year at the chiefs the
ravens at the steelers what the hell cal
mcnair did you expect from bill o'brien
the first three weeks of the season the
only thing you can fault the team for is
coming home and assuming that the own
three vikings were more of a cupcake
than they were they shouldn't have
assumed they were getting the jets they
should have assumed that they were
getting a team that like the texans made
it to the final eight last year i don't
get it and the more i have a chance to
process it shireen the more it stinks to
me and i already knows and look i'm not
going to throw jack eastwood under the
bus yet but i know there are some people
in league circles that are already
suggesting to me that easter bee saw an
opportunity to manipulate mcnair into
getting rid of o'brien and letting
easter be essentially run the show and
hire a new coach and what we see so far
common sense suggests that's exactly
what's going on
yeah because jack easterby is saying
there's no question about that it's just
it's crazy that you change coaches in
the middle of season this early
in a season because you're only four
games in and i realize this team is not
going anywhere and you know who is the
happiest about this of anybody not just
my family and friends down in houston
but the miami dolphins are the happiest
about this situation right now because
they own the first and second round
picks of the houston texans and they're
gonna be high picks by all accounts
i get why they fired him i don't get
now why now is the time to fire him
these mid-season coaching changes
usually don't work out
again the texans are a bad team they
were going to be a bad team but why not
wait till the end of the year to do this
you're not going anywhere this season
that much is obvious you try to build
and get what you can out of this year
and start looking to 2021 and and now
they've made that move to start looking
at 2021 but they have no idea who their
head coach is and and you're not going
to hire a head coach now i mean it gives
you no advantage to fire him right now
to go out and find a head coach there
are no head coaches available at this
moment
and romeo cornell per multiple reports
and john mclean was the first one your
friend from the houston chronicle he
reported the news that o'brien is out
reported the news that romeo cornell
will become the interim head coach and
also
and i don't know if john has put this in
writing anywhere but i texted john and
asked is jackie used to be staying that
was my first question is this a cleaning
of the house or is this a handing of the
keys to easter bee and he used to be
staying so look and again i'm not here
to
pass along some of the strong opinions
that people who have worked with jack
easterby may have about him this is a
guy who has finagled his way with a
great
what's the word i'm looking for line of
it's a four-letter word that starts with
s and ends with t i'm not going to say
that word for obvious reasons i don't
want to join billy o'brien in looking
for a new job but the reputation that's
out there and see here's what happens
here's how sheree let me peel back the
curtain a little bit break down the
fourth wall the people who are reporters
and who rely upon access and information
and there's a symbiosis there
a lot of times they're reluctant to say
what they're really hearing and to tell
people what's really going on the
reality is there's suspicion that jackie
easterbee is a guy who's an opportunist
a guy who has charmed cal mcnair a guy
who has essentially manipulated cal
mcnair with this line of something that
has convinced cal mcnair that easter b
knows what he's doing and easter bee is
the guy who should be entrusted to
rebuild the franchise and the idea
that easter bee has already emerged from
this implosion that has claimed bill
o'brien after only four games a year
after they were in the round of eight
common sense points to
easter bee
being number one on the right side of
this
and number two presumably consulted
before the decision was made i doubt cal
mcnair just fired bill o'brien without
taking the temperature of jack easterby
and
look he he's the winner congratulations
jack you win you're the dog that caught
the car now figure out what the hell
you're going to do with it
and that's the thing mike what do you do
with that you don't have any picks you
don't have any money
and and it goes back even further to
when
before bill o'brien took over his gm if
you look at the dwayne brown trade to
seattle they gave him a way to seattle
for nothing which
precipitated them to go out and get
larry laramie tunsil from the dolphins
and they gave up way too much because
they were desperate and then they had to
give up too much money for him because
they had spent too much in draft capital
to go get him and then the deandre
hopkins trade the best receiver in
football we're going to trade him away
and in this receiver by committee
approach is going to work great and we
think david johnson is one of the best
running backs in football and he's going
to cure our offense
no it hasn't worked none of that has
worked it's just been terrible and so
you know i if you're a coach and you
have opportunities to go elsewhere
when it comes down to it in the off
season or whenever they really start
that coaching search i'm going somewhere
else i'm not going to coach the houston
texans for jack easter b for what they
have talent-wise and the cap the draft
capital they have or don't have and the
money that they don't have moving
forward this just to me looks like a
team that's in decline for a really long
time not just this year but for future
years this is a terrible football team
with a franchise quarterback to whom
they gave a contract that
in total value new money
is second only to patrick mahomes and
frankly and we broke this all down at
the time
the desean watson contract better for
the player than the mahomes contract for
the kansas city chiefs and that
in and of itself
shireen makes the job
attractive because usually what happens
is
when you
have a vacancy
you don't have a quarterback job number
one how are we going to get a
quarterback what are we going to do for
a quarterback now there's also a risk
here that as jack easterbee identifies
the candidates to take over in 2021 you
need to find somebody who you can trust
when they tell you yes we're all in with
desean watson and that needs to be the
fundamental prerequisite for the job an
offensive-minded head coach who has a
plan for maximizing desean watson it
can't be a wolf in sheep's clothing like
josh mcdaniels when he became the
broncos head coach and his first order
of business was to get rid of jay cutler
see once you sign the contract that
guarantees you four or five years of pay
you have a lot of power
so
part of the game is if you really don't
want desean watson but you very much
want to be an nfl head coach saying what
they want to hear
and then once you get the job well you
know what i was wrong about desean
watson now that i have a chance to watch
him practice watch his decision making
you know what maybe he's not the right
guy for this team and i i
i i
i don't believe any of that i think he
is the right guy for the team but now
you've introduced this new dynamic that
there is a chance there's someone out
there who gets that job that thinks he
knows better that thinks that deshaun
watson isn't the answer and part of the
challenge as they screen candidates is
to make sure they find somebody who can
be believed when he says yes deshawn is
my guy because that's now a wrinkle in
all of this that needs to be on the
radar screen as the texans pick their
next head coach and i'll tell you what
you you want you want to be sure
that you're getting a guy
that's all in with deshaun watson you
know who they need to hire shireen
oh yeah you know absolutely i know who
they need to hire you go you go to
cleveland and you get to give that guy
whatever he wants to come to houston
and let me tell you let me tell you
i've never met jack easterby
but
i my guess is there are some personality
similarities between easter bee and dabo
swinney and maybe that makes the town
not big enough for both of them
but yeah that's that's your guy you want
to get the most out of desean watson you
go hire dabo and you don't have to worry
about a trojan horse who's going to show
up and tell you after one season you
know what i think we're wrong about
deshawn watts and we need somebody else
at quarterback
and i i think that's exactly the right
move for the texans to make to go get
him i mean that there's been no one
who's been a bigger supporter of desean
watson than dabo and and he's this guy
and so that gives him a chance to work
with deshawn watson again it gives him a
chance to do it in the nfl we know we
know he's losing his quarterback trevor
lawrence is i'm sure coming out after
this season so it would be a perfect
opportunity for him to go coach the
texans and coach his former quarterback
and see what he can do in the nfl can he
duplicate his success in college in the
nfl it's only been done we know by a
handful of guys jimmy johnson being the
premier example of that but it would
give him a chance to go see if he can do
that and i'm sure he thinks he can do
that so that i would if i'm jack
easterby that would be my first phone
call to make and you could make that
phone call now and just kind of put it
out there that hey this is waiting for
you at the end of the year if you're
interested in it
i just got a text from a general manager
who will remain nameless because i must
protect all my sources easter bee got
him man you called it last year i don't
remember calling it last year but i'll
take credit for it total brutus job so
and and and again and you know
and folks i i don't
i i hope that this doesn't happen often
where something occurs literally minutes
before the show starts and we have no
opportunity to even think about what
we're going to say and we're just saying
whatever comes into our brains that's
not the way that i want to operate
although you know a lot of times i
operate that way just because of lack of
preparation but at least i want to have
the chance to not prepare i don't like
not having the chance to not prepare so
this is all unvarnished reaction from
shireen and me as people who have
followed the sport closely and
understand the way that the sausage gets
made as to what may have happened as to
what probably happened and as to what
happens next so
uh
interesting to say the least as to how
this is going to play out for the texans
and we can't rule out this dynamic and
this is one of the reasons why i'm not a
big fan
of
of firing a coach in season and hiring
an interim coach
you can have an artificial bump in the
performance of the team
because players who don't want to have
to wonder
what the new boss is going to do
to them individually
the players step up
because they want to help the interim
head coach get the permanent head
coaching job
and that rarely works because if they
step up and it happened with romeo
cornell in kansas city after todd haley
was fired back in
2012 i believe it was
the
chief stepped up romeo got the job and
then they went back to being the team
that got
that got the first coach fired so uh
that that's always a mistake and and
look romeo cornell is a great and
respected coach but
um
hopefully jack easterby and cal mcnair
won't allow themselves to be influenced
by
the team going six and six over the
final 12 games and you still take
advantage of the opportunity to hire the
best person to be the coach but again
eastern is going to be the fly in the
ointment and needs to be may think hey
you know what if we get the job to
cornell i i'm in full power i'm in
control cornell's gonna do whatever i
want i run the show you bring in dabo
swinney dabo may see through jack and
jack may be the one who gets thrown
overboard next so a lot of compelling
dynamics that that are coming into play
here shireen and the texans are now a
very interesting team to watch the rest
of the year regardless of what they do
when it's time to play games
yeah no question and my phone is
lighting up right now i grew up in the
houston area and i've heard for weeks if
not months that they needed to fire bill
o'brien so there's a lot of happiness in
houston right now regardless of how this
got done i know the fans are excited
that bill o'brien's gone and it probably
was time seven years hasn't hasn't
gotten them to where they think they
need to go and and whether they had the
talent to beat kansas city or not the
the fact remains that they were way up
on the chiefs in the first half and blew
it and lost big and so um they're
excited bill o'brien's gone we'll see
what the future holds for the texans
only one team has ever come back from an
0-4 start to make the postseason and
that's the 92 chargers and we know the
position who's the coach who's the coach
expanded
uh who's the coach
come on i don't know he was a coach
talking to college guys who went to the
nfl bobby ross first year bobby ross
bobby ross owen bobby ross owen
they came back
yep
and i don't look
you're right with expanded playoffs
there's a chance nobody's ruled out and
maybe they will see an uptick who knows
look bill o'brien's a hell of a coach
but again i still think he needed
someone there to balance him out and it
was never going to be easy to be in this
all started shereen
when they had this great plan
that they were going to fire brian gaine
in june
and they were going to hire nick casario
away from the patriots and it all fell
apart when the patriots called bs
and said no no we we've we've got no we
we've got concerns about this
and they filed the tampering charge
against the texans the texans backed off
they went with no gm
and it was fine see that's the thing
bill o'brien in the dual role was
validated by the decision to make him
the gm after the season making it to the
final eight cal mcnair was happy with
what he saw well behind the scenes
somebody was working on cal mcnair to
come to a different conclusion and that
culminated in bill o'brien being fired
today
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports